on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui mais venant parler d'un temps de
6000 sa mort lundi puis cette semaine je
veux répondre à une question
commentaires suggestions qui venue du
public sur les langues autochtones comme
quoi ce serait vraiment agréable
justement que radio canada puis ça
ferait des ressources en ligne ou
peut-être vidéo autour de la langue qui
nous vous comprendrez peut-être pourquoi
j'ai accroché sur la requête vu que line
où est ma langue maternelle mais que je
n'allais je ne la parle pas de façon
courante c'est encore un grand défi pour
moi de l'apprendre et d'essayer de la
parler à 40 3 mais savez ce défi que je
veux surmonter avant justement que je
pense dans l'autre monde
et pourquoi j'ai pris cette question en
particulier parce que c'est pas la
première fois que je réponds aux
questions linguistiques mais c'est
vraiment parce que on est en 2022 et
2022 marque le début de la décennie des
langues autochtones et là vous
comprendrez pourquoi on va en parler
énormément que ça devenait un sujet
d'actualité parce que malheureusement au
canada et au québec les langues
autochtones ne sont pas reconnus de
façon officielle comme le français et
l'anglais
pourtant ce sont des langues qui
habitent le territoire depuis des
milliers d'années donc on pourrait dire
qu'elles sont assez officielle dans ce
pays mais malheureusement au niveau des
gouvernements et bien sûr faut voir
comme un des effets de la colonisation
un des effets des pensionnats aussi de
vouloir défaire tout construit culturel
des nations pour pouvoir instaurer une
culture dominante eh bien les langues
font partie des choses qui ont été
conduits cherché à détruire
par chance avec la commission vérité
réconciliation c'est quand même quelque
chose qui est ressorti beaucoup parce
que ça a été une des manières de je
dirais d'abuser mentalement et
spirituellement de nos aînés s'étaient
de leur empêcher de les ordonner même
des punitions corporelles
quand il parlait leur propre langue donc
tout le traumatisme autour des langues
existe est encore très vivant pour
beaucoup des générations d'enfants qui
ont été au pensionnat saleh à mener
aussi les enfants qui visait à leurs
enfants à eux au bas c'est bien que tu
parle français anglais toit plus de
facilité probablement dû au fait que eux
mêmes se sont fait ce qui m'avait
varloper par le système des pensions
donc aujourd'hui avec la décennie avec
la réconciliation avec tout ce qui s'en
vient on parle de pouvoir regagner
justement tout ce droit à l'accès
linguistique justement al alagui nous
pour moi dans mon corps et la demande
qui t'ai fait était fait par exemple ce
qui est assez
beau pour moi par une personne qui l'a
lecteurs pourquoi je dis aussi que
ce qu'on peut prouver à travers la
réconciliation à travers les dernières
années' que l'intérêt des personnes
allochtone s'agir du plus grand public
canadien envers la culture des
communautés autochtones a amené une
validation autour de chercher à protéger
finances et rendre disponibles et les
cours de langues les ressources de
langues les applications négocié vous en
trouverez de plus en plus justement que
peut acheter sur google store ce rapport
qui peuvent être de mise dans votre
téléphone et pourquoi mais parce que
puis et de gens qui veulent la parlait
plus et de gens qu'ils voient l'intérêt
et qui voit l'importance aussi culturel
et historique de restaurer ce qui a été
détruit par les pensionnats et mais plus
il ya du financement plus de support qui
viennent ce politiques qui viennent des
institutions envers les langues
comprendre quand j'étais jeune nous on
avait des cours de langues aux primaires
après maternelle au secondaire même si
on avait
l'école secondaire dans notre communauté
mais francis le secondaire pour beaucoup
de gens à l'accessibilité aux cours de
langues sur communauté ou en dehors des
communautés et des nuls
pareillement pour le sujet et
dernièrement des cours de langues
autochtones s'offrent dans les
universités parce qu'il ya eu des
demandes des étudiants universitaires et
parce que les programmes ont été créés
par dans les universités d'ailleurs j'ai
la chance d'avoir ma man ray ni
vêtements en laine qui donnent les cours
de langue et nous d'ailleurs très en
demande parce que de plus en plus de
gens veulent prendre des cours de langue
nous plutôt que 30 peut-être des cours
de mandarin ou d'espagnol à l'université
prendre un cours d'une langue qui est
sur son territoire ça devient quelque
chose qui guérit de quoi dans la
relation donc c'est une très belle très
beau processus mais pour ceux qui
rompent à lugnorre sitôt je vous
recommande chaudement pour la langue et
nous les chèques à pêche qui depuis des
années
créer du matériel créer des livres créer
des sites internet qu'on peut aller
consulter et même des dictionnaires en
ligne avec des exercices
de
deux langues qui même des exercices pour
pratiquer comment le dire et comment
l'entente selon la région dont tu viens
parce que c'est une des distinctions le
lac saint jean et la basse-côte-nord
auront pas les même prononciation aux
langues même il ya une lettre qui sera
joie c'est une distinction de l'anguille
est bien de plus en plus de cours dans
plus en plus de trois ans offre et voilà
le vent qu'un le krill abénakis vous
allez pouvoir avoir des cours adaptés au
territoire sur lequel vous vous trouvez
mais ce qui est vraiment majeur c'est le
sport qui vient du public est justement
de beaucoup je dirais beaucoup de
l'éveil de se rendre compte et c'est
vrai que son protégé les langues
autochtones puis pour passer leurs
foyers ils sont nés sur ses terres hydro
ne sais pas ce que je peux retourner en
france pour le français ou que je peux
retourner en angleterre ou en espagne
pour d'autres langues où ils sont sur
leur territoire mer mais c'est de dire
ici présentement sur ce territoire là
les langues autochtones sont fragilisés
il se trouve à nulle part dont et plus
le temps avance plus ce qu'ils pensent
les langues commencent à partir et donc
on perd des distinctions qui ont été
enlevés juste avant la nouvelle
génération qui parle leur langue mais
qui parle de point de vue urbain et bien
cette connexion là doit être fait et
avec le support avec les deux membres
avec l'appui je remplis avec une
décennie que vous nous amener à
réfléchir peut-être la prochaine
chronique que je vais pas faire sur la
langue va vous et nouveautés on va
protéger les gens des autochtones sur
leur territoire alors merci beaucoup à
la personne qui m'a envoyé cette
question il s'était pas nous en avril
parce qu'elles nourrissent beaucoup ma
réflexion elle me donne envie de
partager des ressources qui des fois ne
sont pas connus du grand public mais
beaucoup connu dans les communautés donc
ce n'est pas les chèques et pêche et
s'était pas lavé voir dans vos
universités 6e des cours qui s'offrent
dans des langues autochtones écouter de
la musique parce que justement à cause
d'une époque reconnue comme une langue
officielle elle joue de moins en moins
dans les radios dans la télévision donc
aller chercher ses ressources année plus
on va chercher ses ressources et plus
elle va pouvoir être devant demander du
financement et pour amener cette
ressource à valhalla grand public et ce
n'est pas non plus à mettre quelques
applications sur votre téléphone moi ça
me sauve la vie
alors cette baisse